we're pleased to be joined in studio by
virginia governor glenn younkin gov
great to see you um thanks for being
here um
so
they still have a blind spot on this
issue they don't understand why parents
want their kids taught actual subjects
not what they're pushing on the kids no
and we saw this last year through our
entire race where parents were standing
up saying we're in charge of our
children not bureaucrats not politicians
and yet we saw the progressive liberals
continually try to inject themselves
between parents and their children and
oh by the way keep classrooms closed
dictate explicit material that families
don't want in their children's education
and oh by the way finally lower
standards and tell them if you just do
okay it's good enough and then what we
saw laura of course was
virginians stood up and said no it
wasn't republicans versus democrats it
was all virginians parents from all
walks of life said we've had it and then
we see the test scores come out and we
see these scores come out tell us that
that not only were the were the closed
schools detrimental to our children but
what they were being taught being taught
what to think as opposed to how to think
all of a sudden resulted in a 20-year
loss in learning in math and in english
across the country and we've seen the
same thing in virginia how's that good
for minorities it just is and in fact
people talk about averages
and it's worse for minorities for black
virginians for latino virginians by the
way for for virginians who have english
as a second language for virginians who
are disabled and and what we continually
see is the progressive liberals ignore
all that
and all they want to talk about all they
want to try to inject on our children is
a political philosophy or a gender
identity philosophy they want to move
parents out of their lives um governor i
have to get to this so california passed
this law last month that banned the sale
of new gas powered vehicles by 2035 but
it's phased in pretty quickly
aggressively
and i didn't know this as a resident of
virginia i didn't know this
but
virginia tracks california so right now
the commonwealth of virginia is poised
to ban the sale of gas-powered cars by
2035
and you said you're gonna try to you
know marshall the legislative uh force
behind undoing this yeah we have to we
have to so of course when the democrats
controlled the house of senate and of
course the governor's office single
party rule by progressive liberals
rather than do their job and represent
the people that elected them to be there
they outsourced it to california and
worse yet we've got to have 35 percent
ev purchases in 2026 so no longer do
parents get to decide what happens in
their children's lives no longer in fact
do people get to choose what car they
want to drive how far they can drive and
how they want to drive and no longer
would the democrats who were elected to
represent virginians want to do their
job and this is why virginians said
enough and i think we're going to see
enough shouted across the country this
november now um a lot of people are
seeing your campaigning outside of the
commonwealth of virginia i mean we want
you to stay in virginia all the time but
you're all over the place you're very
popular at 55
approval which is nice to see for a
republican governor or any governor
frank but it's great to see for you the
washington times wrote about you saying
that younkin's been stepping up his
out-of-state appearances to help
republican gubernatorial candidates
across the country which is feeding
murmurs
about his presidential ambitions
what are your presidential ambitions
well my ambitions right now are to be
the best governor that i possibly can in
virginia and we've had a great first
eight months
i'm also finding that there's a great
opportunity for me to support virginia
candidates running for congress and i've
often thought that the road to the
majority in our house of representatives
comes through virginia we've got great
candidates yes lee vega in the seventh
and jenn kiggins in the second uh and
hunk cow in the 10th we can win these
races these are the worst candidates
these are diverse candidates this is the
future of the republican party it's
amazing and and on top of that the the
republican candidates that are running
in states that look just like virginia
last year where joe biden won by five or
ten points and yet you see the issues of
education and inflation and lawlessness
driving people into the republican party
who have never voted for republicans
before and i think we can help and
that's why i've been excited to have a
chance to when i do leave virginia to go
help republican candidates win
governor's races so that they too
can see what it's like to have a
republican governor and see a state
moving as opposed to stalled you're not
giving me anything i'm i'm running for
president i'm focused on 2022 laura are
you renaming some of these community
colleges or allowing these pc names to
remain that's a north ameri era kind of
thing sadly it was done it was done
before
before i was elected what i have been
able to stop is jump in in front of
changes to our history curriculum where
they wanted to no longer identify george
washington as the father of our country
or james madison as the father of our
constitution and i don't believe we
should ever be airbrushing away our
history statues coming down any more
statues no more statues are coming down
but what we can do is teach all of our
history and this is where i think the
progressive liberals miss this which is
we can in fact teach the good and the
bad and oh by the way stand up for
parents in the classroom governor yonkin
it's great to see you congrats on a
great first eight months and i can't see
what happens next thank you so much all
right great to see you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else